[Musique]
la parole aux actes m dissimule sa
marraine depuis cette semaine je veux
souligner le départ d'un homme
extrêmement important pour la nation
unies mais aussi pour les communautés
autochtones
serge bouchard je pense que vous avez dû
voir passer beaucoup de témoignages
beaucoup de reconnaissance du travail
que cet homme fait non seulement pour ma
nation parce que je le sais pertinemment
à coeur dû au travail qui est fait pour
ma nation mais pour les autres nations
et non seulement pour les nations
autochtones mais aussi pour les nations
entre la nation québécoise qui reconnaît
son travail qui reconnaît sa marque sur
justement la capacité de faire la
réconciliation
vous comprendrez que c'est quand même
assez étrange qu'on souligne le travail
d'un anthropologue un homme blanc qui
représente un petit peu ce que beaucoup
de gens vaches qui est la problématique
au sein des communautés autochtones
mais ce qu'il faut pas rater ce qu'il
faut surtout pas rater c'est comment
serge bouchard hausse était la solution
par rapport à la réconciliation comment
on peut travailler justement cette de
reconnexion cette préparation peut venir
justement de notre relation qui ont
souvent été malmenés ou oubliées quand
j'étais jeune j'ai eu la chance très
jeune je ne vois des femmes autochtones
en action je parle je parle souvent des
libéraux mais je parle pas assez souvent
je pense du travail que certains
anthropologues ont fait pour me
permettre de reconnecter de ne pas
perdre des messages qui habituellement
très dans les bibliothèques ou dans les
cinémas dans les lits un peu partout
dans les médias et que comme je suis la
nation innu comme je suis une certaine
pendant longtemps ces messages n'ont pas
été transmis n'a été vu comme un
important donc ne font pas partie de
l'histoire collective québec
cependant serge bouchard a recueilli
près souvent la parole de nos ennemis la
parole les contes les légendes qui
venaient les communautés autochtones et
un livre quand j'étais extrêmement
j'avais 16 ans je suis tombé dessus
c'est les chroniques d'un chasseur de
montagne et le manga koné le geste de
montagne et demi
c'est les paroles de mathieu mr chaumet
qui ont été recueillis par serge et je
voulais un expert de son introduction
et ça va vous expliquer un peu pourquoi
son travail pour moi c'est extrêmement
important
le manuscrit fidèle aux relations de
mathieu la traduction française est
presque littéral et l'adaptation
littéraire est volontairement modeste
dans l'édition du texte j'ai voulu
respecter
l'événement socialité et la chronologie
des commentaires il ya donc un minimum
de manipulations comme mature j'éprouve
des difficultés quand je cherche à
identifier les publics auxquels
s'adresse ce livre j'ai donc pris le
parti de les livrer pour ce qu'il vaut
intrinsèquement sur le plan littéraire
j'ai évité de lui donner un style qu'il
n'aurait certainement pas été honnête
par rapport à la performance originale
du compteur
par ailleurs les textes suggère une
multitude de commentaires ethnographique
à caractère explicative là aussi j'ai
voulu conserver manuscrits sa pureté son
originalité
le texte se comprend par lui-même en
lui-même je vous recommande de le lire
parce que par ce travail est justement
minimale par 7,7 responsable de cette
transmission de la parole de mathieu mr
gauche dans une langue que moi je
pouvais comprendre parce que en tant que
jeunes et nous qui ne pas emmener pas sa
langue avoir accès à la pensée de mes
aînés mais dans une une structure que je
pouvais comprendre cependant ça a été
extraordinaire et je pouvais voyager à
travers le récit de matthew mistoco
chaud sur le territoire à travers les
choses que j'avais expérimenté que
j'avais vu mais dans une pensée innu
donc je trouve qu'il ya beaucoup de
travail qui était bien fait bien
accompli dans le travail je demande un
certain
témoignant de la culture de l'histoire
très longtemps j'étais très méfiant de
ce travail des anthropologues quand
chercher des textes sur les communautés
autochtones sur les peuples autochtones
souvent je voyais une espèce d analyse
qui nous faisait avoir quasiment comme
s'il était en train d'observer des
heures et niall ou des oiseaux et avec
une fausse interprétation genre d'une
vision comme ce sont les autochtones
comme ce sont les is you comme ce sont
les écrits alors que dans ce travail là
qu'ils avaient une [ __ ] une portance de
la parole de l'idéologie de la
compréhension autochtone du territoire
de l'histoire de l'existence donc ça m'a
vraiment fait voir comment un travail
ethnographique ou comment un travail
anthropologique qui va être fait d'une
bonne manière et ça l'a souvent éviter
justement à serge de la partie de ceux
qui comme on disait il y avait souvent
une bande dessinée on utilisait c'était
l'ordre prix cacher la télévision il ya
un anthropologue qui s'en vient c'est à
dire de montrer une espèce de spectacle
de ce qu'ils voulaient voir ce qui nous
a été prêtée de la culture des
communautés autochtones
mais ce qui est vraiment le succès de
serre che non seulement il est venu
observer la culture mais il le véhicule
qui la prennent acte avec la communauté
et c'est ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui
beaucoup de communautés
beaucoup de membres de ma communauté le
remercie pour son travail et vous dit
qu'il ya une manière de faire les choses
qui est bonne et qui nous relier les ans
donc merci beaucoup je suis comme tout
seul char pour le travail et pour la
parole que tu as porté
c'est une belle semaine